3...2...1... Oh dear!!
hey guys. I'm Nate welcome back to the backyard today. We've got a fun experiment that we're going to try
Thanks to the suggestion of Youtube user Robert Vipperman!
Robert wanted to know what would happen if we mixed molten salt with you to the liquid nitrogen or dry ice well today is
Not the day for the liquid nitrogen test
But it is the day to see what happens if we pour molten salt onto dry ice well. We've got our foundry
We've got our salt
And we've got some dry ice let's try mixing them together
Now as a first step what we want to try and do is clean out our crucible all of the crucibles
We've got currently have a residue from other projects in them this one seems to have quite a bit of
aluminum built up on the sides
so we're gonna try and chip out what we can then fire up the foundry and see if we can melt out the rest and
Shake it out. So we have on mostly clean crucible to melt our salt in
We do want a small reservoir in our dry ice to pour the salt into so it doesn't just scatter all over the place
So let's take our drill bit and try and carve a hole down into the ice just a little bit
Alex toasty see how well molten salt pours out of a crucible
Huh, well it's cooled down it certainly bubbled a good amount
But it didn't react horrendously violently at all at least not yet. I guess it's still possible to get there but
Even the salt, that's just on our pavers has cooled down to being solid
Just like our salt inside our dry ice has as well, let's see if we can tip that out
There you go a nice solid chunk of salt right there I
Think the salt and our crucible is still liquid try pouring a little bit more in
skimming some of this aluminum off the top just
melting more aluminum
Goes
Oh
I
Certainly wouldn't want to get that on me
But it's nowhere near the violent kind of reaction that we've seen in other people's channels where they pour salt into water
That is still squishy. It definitely hasn't cooled down all the way
Very hot also very hot still both very hot
All right now, I know this is probably filled
with aluminum
And some other trace metals
But I'm gonna lick it
Surprise of all surprises, it's salty
Alright, now. This is finally cold
Sounds a little less cold, but it's also a little bit thicker and it was poured second so that makes sense now
I'm gonna try and break a piece off of this dry ice
We're gonna see what happens if we drop this dry ice into some molten salt, I know
three two one
Bubbling bubbling bubbling kind of not even a lot just a little bit of bubbling
The dry ice is disappearing a little bit faster than if you just left it out
Not a lot o
One of our pucks broke in half
It's kind of cool, it's got a like a very smooth outside
But you can see that the crystalline structure has begun to form on the inside as a cool ball. Let's hit this with a hammer
Exploded now. It's rock salt
We've got two more experiments that we want to try and we've moved to the dome just in case things get out of hand which
I don't think will be a problem, but better safe than sorry, so let's melt up some more salt, and then try our next experiment
Because I'm not really sure how this is going to react when it's going down into the crucible
I have a plan for how to dip it in there and keep myself a little ways away
I'll take the dry ice and secure it in a pair of tongs
And then I'm gonna use this extended grabber thing to hold the tongs
away from myself
And I'll dip that down into the crucible
I don't really think it's going to explode because neither the dry ice nor the salt will vaporize
Rapidly the same way normal ice would but it is possible that some salt will cool down
Around the dry ice for Michelle
And then the expanding dry ice will cause that to break open so I do want to stay a little bit away
And that's why I'm not just gonna be dipping this directly down into the salt
Ready
Well it's certainly bubbling well
Quite a bit more of a reaction that I thought we would get actually
It's spilling all over our container
Starting to slow down
There it is
Now just floating on the top of the salt
My tongs have become salted together it was just so much salt that built up on the tips
It was in contact with the dry ice so I think it just made it cool down
It's like a salt weld
That was pretty fun
we got a lot more bubbling action than I really thought the last thing we want to try is to take our salt and
then pour it on to a container full of
Broken up dry ice so it's not just pouring it onto one flat piece of dry ice that has a whole board into it in
This case there's just going to be lots of pieces, and it's just going to flow all over all of it
All right
All right here we go. I'll take the crucible. I'm just gonna pour it all over that dry ice
This could be exciting ready three two one
Hmm, I think I expected a little bit more of a reaction when that poured on
The salt poured all over chunks of dry ice
Didn't react a whole lot we got much more of a reaction when we put it into the solid piece of dry ice I found
a whole
Board down into it we got a lot of
Bubbling and popping and it did stay in that chunk and rice ended up casting that puck that was pretty neat
Molten salt versus dry ice the molten salt didn't react terribly violently, but it did bubble and splashed quite a bit
And it's just interesting to see salt as a liquid. It pours very smoothly
It's a pretty runny thin liquid - like it doesn't turn into a consistency like syrup or anything like that
It's almost as thin as water. It seems overall. This is pretty fun
Thank you to Robert for your suggestion of what we should do check your youtube inbox. We're gonna be sending you 25 bucks
Hey guys. Thanks for watching if you're not a subscriber yet
Just hit the bomb to get in the club if you missed our last video or want to see it again
Click up here at the top click down there if you want to see what the internet thinks that you should watch next
That's it for now. Have fun. Be safe and see you tomorrow